president biden said yesterday that the
u.s military is speeding up evacuations
of americans and afghans as the
situation at the kabul airport as you
see deteriorates a cbs news poll finds
that 63 percent of americans support
removing the troops from afghanistan but
74 percent 74 percent rather believe
this withdrawal has gone badly ed
o'keefe is at the white house where he
questioned the president at the news
briefing ed good morning to you the
video and the reports are so upsetting
and disturbing
yeah that's right gail good morning in
addition to that situation in
afghanistan the white house is also
closely tracking that deadly weekend
weather all of it part of arguably the
toughest stretch yet for the biden
presidency because while the situation
in kabul grows even more dangerous
polling as you just showed there shows
the president's overall support is
slipping as he's facing criticism at
home and abroad
we are proving that we can move
thousands of people a day out of kabul
president biden tried to ease concerns
sunday about the u.s withdrawal from
afghanistan there is no way to evacuate
this many people without pain and loss
of heartbreaking images you see on
television
it's just a fact
president said the u.s is now actively
monitoring potential terrorist threats
to americans and afghans
as chaos unfolds in kabul with
particular concern about isis k an isis
affiliate that's an enemy of the taliban
based in afghanistan we're under no
illusions about the threat mr biden
continues to face a litany of criticism
as the u.s executes one of the most
elaborate mass evacuations since world
war ii this is one of the
biggest debacles that we have seen in
the last several decades the white house
is denying what we know is happening on
the ground the president needs to step
up and be the commander-in-chief
according to a new cbs news poll not
only do the majority of americans
believe the withdrawal of u.s forces
from afghanistan has gone badly but
president biden's overall approval
rating has plunged eight points in the
last month his lowest numbers yet
and the survey shows a majority of
americans no longer considered the
president to be competent focused or
effective in the job what would you say
to those americans who no longer believe
that you're up to the job my job is to
make judgments no one else can or will
make i made them i'm convinced i'm
absolutely correct and not deciding to
send more young women and men to war
for a war that in fact is no longer
warranted i think that history is going
to record
this was the logical rational and right
decision to make
so the president plans to meet virtually
tomorrow with the other leaders of g7
countries to discuss the global response
to the situation in afghanistan and he's
also scheduled to hold detailed security
meetings every day this week to track
the progress of the evacuation tony as
dozens of u.s military jets continue
flying people out of afghanistan and as
the president said he thinks history is
on his side ed thank you very much